Now that we've talked about our regions and whether or not our inequality is
satisfied in each of them. Let's make a table to figure out the value of each of
the individual factors within each region and how that affects the value of the
entire quantity that we're interested in, in our inequality. Remember, you don't
need to actually use the inequality we're talking about in this table itself,
but I'll write it here just for reference. So in each column think about the
quantity at the top. Either x minus 4x plus 4, or the product of those two and
then for each of these intervals or values, this on the left tell me if quantity
is positive, negative, or 0. So for example If I'm thinking about x minus 4 and
I let x equal something greater then 4, then x minus 4 is going to be positive.
So fill in the table just like that.